Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, here is a voicemail
about the new Finance Channel. Yes, we have
a finance channel, youtube.com slash Pacman
finance. You know, we get so many voicemails
from people who just don't understand what the
hell I'm talking about. And I usually blame
myself. I must be a terrible communicator.
This caller knows exactly what the Pacman Finance
Channel is and is supposed to be. Take a listen.
Speaker 4: Hey, David, I'd like to thank you so
much for, you know, creating the Pacman Finance
YouTube channel. Thank you. I really like the
content that you've been producing. It's very
simple. Nothing too exquisite. Like talking about
all which stocks should I buy or when should I buy
Tesla? Just really simple personal finance that I
really feel like a lot of people are missing out
today, especially in regards to credit to credit
scores, learning how to budget, stuff like that.
And I mean, and also the fact that, you know,
you're not like Dave Ramsey, that's also a very
refreshing thing. So. Yes, yeah. Again, thank
you so much for creating the Finance Channel.
And I look forward to seeing, you know, seeing the
channel, you know, get up to, you know, 1 million.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, I don't know about a
million subscribers, but I have to tell you,
the Pacman Finance Channel has grown more quickly
out of the gate to 10,000 subscribers than any
other channel or project we've been involved
in. Now, I want to remind everybody I have
nothing to sell you. It is an alternative to
these right wing finance folks, Dave Ramsey,
who gives financial advice, but he's anti-vax
and has horrible employment practices he's been
accused of at his organization. You don't need
that. You can get all the information without
the anti-vax. NADERY Okay. So indeed, there's no
stock picking. There's none of that. Check out
the channel YouTube.com slash Pacman finance more
than 11,000 subscribers. It's all free. There is
nothing you can even could pay for if you wanted.
It's all free. So many basic personal finance
topics. I always say we should start teaching
this stuff to 12 year olds and we don't. So
we're offering it for free on the channel. Okay.
Recent topics The Hidden Cost of Low Prices. How
Low Prices Can Actually Lead to more spending.
Is it better to pay with cash or credit cards?
Understanding the math of retirement. Why in
health insurance is important. Roth versus versus
traditional IRAs. Understanding net worth. Why
the stock market has been down. Improving your
credit score. Why you shouldn't bother trying to
time the market. All of these things. It is just
three simple topics. Okay. YouTube.com, slash
pacman finance. If more folks knew the stuff and
understood the content that was on this channel,
we would have way fewer people fall for financial
scams, number one. And in general, people would
be better off in terms of understanding their
financial position. Know stock picks. If you're
expecting stock picks, this is not the channel
for you. If you're expecting anti-vaxx, this is
not the channel for you. Go to Dave Ramsey for the
anti-vax finance stuff. YouTube.com slash pacman
finance. Okay, enough on today's bonus show. Great
bonus show today. Yet another acquittal. Related
to Durham, Trump and Republicans have been saying,
Oh, Durham is going to get this person, that
person. It's going to be crazy. Yet another
Durham acquittal. It's a humiliation for the
right wingers. The White House is pushing ahead
on a plan to research the idea of cooling the
earth by reflecting sunlight back out into space,
discussed in science fiction for decades.
Could it become a reality? We will talk
about it today on the bonus show. And also, I
know that I just told you that the new British
prime minister replacing Boris Johnson is
Liz Truss. She's been in what, a few weeks.
She's already only hanging on by a thread. Party
members are calling for her to be removed. And
this could be one of the shortest tenures as
British prime minister in British history.
Fascinating. I guess not good for Liz Truss,
but maybe good for the people of the UK. All of
those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else who makes
money to fund themselves is bad. Thank your
lucky stars every day. You're not David Pakman.
Speaker 1: Well, many of our viewers do think
they're lucky stars every single day that
they have access to the bonus show. Sign
up at join Packman dot com. We will see you
on the bonus show or otherwise back here to.